the ex-president of the United States
Bill Clinton and Gavin Nome went down to
Mexico to hang
out um they went to a cool Resort I
would love to
be a a mortar in pestl of guacamole
sitting at the table listening to this
crime family give the last bit of wisdom
this is all they have left the standard
bearers of the democratic party which is
the
clintons are telling Gavin Nome and his
wife how to
become the new Power couple because the
Obamas can't do the Republican part is
in utter
disarray you meaning that there's
infighting and the Democratic party as
well but both both political parties the
Republican party you have the Wall
Street types they want like Nikki haly
you want you have like
um you know the magga people for
Trump you know I don't know I don't know
who's wants V but I guess people that
are people on Reddit maybe but this is
the Clinton's telling the news you know
and what a great
dinner because you know there's some
Bill's really just saying
listen I let it get away from me this is
he's you know there's a beach walk with
him and Gavin there's a Beach Walk walk
with him and Gavin right because they're
kind of a similar guy Gavin's boy you
know what I mean he was married to that
chick who's now dating Trump
Jr Kimberly guilfoil Newsome yeah so
Gavin's like kind of a pretty boy he
bill they speak the same language
Hillary does not speak the language
of Harvey
Weinstein's test ifier testifying about
the penis woman Hillary doesn't speak
her language cuz she's like a real wife
Hillary was never a real wife
Hillary's you know Hillary's a is a is a
problem and she wants her own thing and
this you know so when when her and
Hillary have to talk Hillary's not
really excited by that she probably is
but Bill definitely does a beach walk
with Gavin where he could hey it got
away from
me and just you know just you know you
got to be careful out there because they
you know it's not like it used to be
this is a different world now can you
imagine just Bill Clinton you know at
the end of it being like hey I mean
listen and you know like he definitely
says to Gavin like he goes they're
trying to say that I was like doing
stuff on Epstein's Island and you
Gavin's got like looks at him strangely
and Clinton's like can you believe that
like they're trying to tie me into that
and Gavin's like I
these Clint's like these kinon types
they're trying to tie me in to this uh
eping stuff I mean that's how perverted
these people are it's how sick they are
and Gavin's kind of like like going like
like you Gavin's face kind of
like yeah no it's these people man
they'll just I mean they don't care
about the truth at all Bill's like right
I I mean it's it's insane what they're
doing and they're having a little Beach
Walk and Bill's Bill's a really smart
guy so Bill Bill's not out there like
people think that Bill's probably like
and then I this one and that one and
then we drown one of them like he's not
they're not doing that he's like setting
it up so he's telling Gavin like they're
lying about me they're going to lie
about you this is what they do they lie
and you have to get one step ahead of
their lives that's where the fun comes
in that's where the fun comes in cuz
Bill's like yeah yeah yeah you gotta get
a you gotta go one step ahead of their
lives because they're gonna they're
gonna make up a bunch about you
they made up a lot of stuff about me and
Hillary they never stop because the
cleans are boomers so they're the
victims the cleans are there only to
complain to Gavin and his wife about how
badly they've been treated and Hillary's
like and they went at me they never
stopped from the minute I raised my head
I became the symbol of everything that
they hated about women and about feminis
and you know Gavin and a wife are
sitting there and there having some
tequila and drinking to Don Julio Blanco
and they're like yeah yeah know it's we
saw it you guys were just I mean they NE
I mean they never I mean short Bill's
not perfect but they never
stop and it's annoying it's annoy you
know they're just the the news are
sitting there but they but the news are
sucking it all up because the news are
like how do we how do we convince the uh
Country That We're Not Gonna you know
everybody over how do we do that how do
we do that and nome's not Clinton like
Clinton's really good or he was really
good but it's got I would just love to
be sitting there and listening it's 90%
the Clint is complaining 90% but then
there's going to be 10% like here's what
you got to do to get the things you want
and that would be the interesting stuff
yeah here's the people to talk to these
are the guys that have to like you
here's the way it
works you know you need a bigger War
chest than you used to you know why do
we really think Hillary lost
D but a lot of it is just complaining
it's probably very boring what would be
great is if the clintons decided to kill
them like if they just killed
them and then just that was it like if
the clintons just decided to uh
poison gav new for what I I don't know
uh even why they would do I recorded
patreon episode years ago was called
Bill and Hill's last kill about how
there will be a time when they just have
one more kill that's it there's like one
more guy to get rid of but they there's
no reason to kill these people here but
it would be fun there'd be something
beautiful on Shakespearean about Nome
and the wife going to get the secrets
from the clintons and the secrets going
and here's the biggest secret and then
Gavin and his wife dead in the guacamole